die afg feiert erfolge weil sie schwache
gegen noch schwächere aufhetzt und das
wird die debattenkultur weiter verändern
in deutschland und natürlich auch im
bundestag
wir schalten wir live nach berlin zu
albrecht humboldt im albrecht wie
bereitet man sich denn da jetzt vor auf
die neuen afg abgeordneten
hier finden gerade die ersten
stellproben für die nächste
legislaturperiode statt und das wird
natürlich schon ein platzproblem über
700 abgeordnete vielleicht bis zu 80 von
der afd
wo sollen sie hin man könnte sagen die
neue fdp fraktion hat oder ist bald ein
volk ohne raum schuldig
kleiner scherz ist muss ja auch mal sein
nicht das zdf wird ja eh bald dicht
gemacht wahrscheinlich
höchstwahrscheinlich aber herr welke
erwecke was hier passiert ist echt
kindergarten
jetzt will keiner neben den sitzen also
wie albern ist das denn das sind
gewählte abgeordnete man hat extra die
regeln für den alterspräsidenten
geändert nur damit dass keiner von der
afg wird in den ausschüssen werden jetzt
extra stühle nur für asd leute
angeschafft ja nee also da kann ich
darüber lachen
herwig
darüber kann ich nicht lachen manche
wollen jetzt verhindern dass die den
vorsitzenden des mächtigen
haushaltsausschusses stellen
man hilft denen noch sich als opfer zu
fühlen gut immerhin kommt die kantine
hier der afg entgegen da gibt es jetzt
jeden tag nur noch schweinefleisch also
alles nur noch aus schwei sogar die
cocktails
gut klar wir dürfen von der afg
natürlich keine regelrechte arbeit
erwarten die leben nur von der
provokation hier eine afd abgeordnete in
thüringen hat zb mal die regierung
gefragt wie viele homosexuelle
eigentlich im land leben einfach damit
man mal eine zahl hat falls man die mal
abholen muss oder dass oder oder so
verstehe aber was wollen die denn
langfristig keine kompromisse keine
koalition er jedenfalls nicht als
juniorpartner ja hier der band mit dem
neuen fünf-jahres-plan aber es ist der
einzige weg der zum vollständigen und
vollständiger sieg also so gesehen
sollte man die bude hier auch gar nicht
mehr großartig umbauen nach dem
vollständigen sieg brauchen wir kein
parlament mehr
ich würde sagen man stellt die
vorhandenen stühle einfach anders hin
das muss doch nicht auf ewig so aussehen
mal neue formen ausprobieren was weiß
ich so was hier einfach mal frische
ideen nein danke albrecht und meine
damen und herren
[Applaus]